jonathan is with us in Texas hey
Jonathan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi miss Ramsey take about and beyond
sure what's up so I had a quick question
I'm trying to follow the order of the
snowball effect with a catch one of my
student loans that I had I had a moment
where I had to get out of that stood
alone in a really quick manner so I
panicked and I actually pulled out a
hardship for one king loan for my
investments to take care about student
loan it was just a little bit of family
drama that had to you know require that
to happen so now I have three student
loans and one hardship loan it's my this
hardship loan after they didn't do this
before listening to your program so
knowing what I know now I probably would
have done it all of them said things
differently
so I'm trying I'm considering it
actually about attacking this specific
loan first even though it's not my
smallest debt why just because it's um
so I think after hearing your program I
was just worried about the risk
regarding you know my employment along
with just like how that's just tied to
my investment so I was just wondering if
a I should attack that first was the
first question no I was just list I
would work on smallest to largest how
much debt have you got total um roughly
forty thousand okay and how much of that
is this hardship loan about twenty five
percent so that's about ten thousand
eleven thousand roughly okay and is it
all stall the whole forty thousand or
student loans
the remaining yes but the interesting
thing about this hardship loan is that I
can't throw any additional money into it
I know delicious okay I didn't know that
401k loans are always know why you're
here and I'm well I'm not 401k loans are
all that way and so what you have to do
is when you get to that one on the left
on the debt snowball
you have to just pile up cash until you
have the
and then pay it off in one what you can
pay it in one lump sum right but you can
systematically add extra to it they
won't allow that you either pay the
regular payment or you just pay it off
those are your two options so you have
to save up and pay it off so you have
$10,000 on it and how many loans are in
front of it on the debt snowball then so
there's two loans in front of it
and they are melting what seventeen
thousand eight thousand on one and then
nine thousand on the other I'm sorry
okay so it's eight nine ten yeah eight
nine ten and then about fourteen okay
and your your income is what eighty
thousand a year okay so how quickly will
you pay this forty thousand off making
eighty depending on a couple of bonuses
that my company usually pays I would say
anywhere between 17 and 24 a month I
think it's just dependent on a couple of
things I actually just became a father
for the first time so a couple of the
complexities yeah yeah you got other
stuff going on that's good so so does
your wife work outside the home oh no
not at this point okay we were
considering about her you know going
back to the workplace that's okay not
requiring it I'm just saying okay so you
got enough going on that you're thinking
it's probably 18 it's not 24 it's 12 to
18 is what it should be okay all 40
making Haiti you just got a lot of other
stuff going on you got a lot of
ticky-tacky stuff with a new baby and
odds and ends that are little budget
dingers little mosquitoes flying around
the budget that are eating on it but and
that's normal that's okay so yeah the
point is you're gonna be free very soon
either way so if you flip it and paid it
first your you know they're almost equal
it's eight nine ten right and so if you
flip it and pay it first it's not that
big a deal because they're very very
close if you want to do that that's fine
I'm not only mad about it I'm pretty
much a stickler or sticking to the debt
snowball unless there's a reason the
problem is you're gonna have to really
work your emotions up and your wife's
because you're going to see out
solutely no relief until you pay $10,000
okay
you see I'm saying it's like an all or
nothing because you have to save up and
pay the stupid thing and so if you're
paying off 40 so it's gonna take you
like four months right to pay the thing
off roughly if we're on it if we're on a
12 to an 18 month schedule and so um
yeah if you won't go that direction it's
okay
I might it doesn't matter you the BA
bottom line is you're gonna be there so
fast that you're not at risk okay
but I liked it I liked that you're
thinking it through yeah and you're
using both sets of paradigms both sets
of decision-making tools you're saying
I'm looking at the math and the risk and
that's bothering me
and yet I understand the behavior
aspects of the debt snowball and I want
to do it that way but I'm kind of
thinking this way and I like that you're
you know here's what's happening you're
thinking this is great news that's what
happens to most people what most
people's money screwed up they don't
think they're not intentional they don't
do stuff on purpose stuff happens to
them they don't happen to stuff the
power of intentionality the power of
proactivity and you've got all of that
so our discussion here is minor the
these fine points of what we're
discussing or minor you're attacking it
you got a baby I'm cleaning up this mess
I've learned my lesson I'm making
emotional decisions and bail myself out
of weird stuff and I'm not doing that
anymore and I don't like what this
represents and I'm getting after it and
and I think you're gonna be done you
might even be done in twelve months just
because you're so focused you're
thinking you're thinking you're focusing
and you that's how you win good job man
thanks for calling in folks you realize
that if you want to win at something you
just concentrate on it if you want to
win at something you concentrate on it a
lot and you get better and you learn and
you get better and you concentrate on it
and you train and you train your brain
and you train your muscle
and you train the people around you and
when you concentrate on something they
go well you know so-and-so is doing that
they're not gonna do this this is what
they're doing there that person is known
for focusing they're known for training
and so you know call my son up I said
hey you want to you don't play golf
Saturday morning dad I got a spartan
race you know I've been training for
that I got to do I got to do my runs I
got to do my training and so yeah I know
that I know he's training for something
what you focus on is what you win at and
you don't go to something that's said
strenuous you don't do the big things in
life raising kids and marriage and
career success and your spiritual
walking taking care of your body and
building wealth these things are not
accidental occurrences no one becomes
successful accidentally it's an
intentional act